[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TIRES SQUEAL]
- Alan, this species of cartoon
has been extinct since 1998.
I mean, these haven't been
seen on TV since the golden era
of animation.
And, and-- what?
- La!
- It's-- it's the
Warner brothers.
- And the Warner sister!
- [LAUGHS] That's-- yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
- He-- he did it.
That, that, that, that crazy
son of a gun actually did it.
- Clean vectored outlines,
wide screen format.
- Theses don't look like reruns.
[HONK]
- Well, they're not.
[LAUGHS] I reanimated them.
- We are gonna make a
fortune with this show.
- How zany are they?
- Oh, to the max.
[SPLAT]
Of course, then there's
Pinky and the Brain.
- Pinky and the Brain?
You said you're bringing
back Pinky and the Brain?
- Mm-hmm.
- Say it again.
- We're bringing back
Pinky and the Brain.
- Put your head
between your knees.
- Boingy, boingy,
boingy, boingy!
- Where are they going?
- Home.
Welcome to "Animaniacs."
- (SINGING) Those are the facts!